welcome back to part two of web scraping
with google sheets in the last video we
covered import html
import data and import feed but in this
video we're going to cover the final
command
import xml which can help us extract
data we otherwise couldn't before
so import xml takes two arguments a url
and an xpath
when you call import xml it fetches an
xml document with the content from the
website you're trying to parse through
and xpath
can help us navigate through those
elements and attributes of these xml
documents
so if you're unfamiliar with xpath
that's totally fine since we won't be
going too in depth in this video
but it is pretty powerful so if you want
to learn more i'd highly recommend
checking out the w3schools tutorial that
walks through the basic syntax
and i'll go ahead and link this in the
description but i'm going to assume that
you don't know much
xpath so we're going to be using a
chrome extension called selector gadget
that you can go ahead and download and
that'll actually fetch the appropriate
xpaths so once you've got that
downloaded we can go ahead and get
started
the first example we're going to be
working with is craigslist and we're
going to want to scrape all of these
listings
so we'll start by grabbing the url at
the top and pasting it in our google
sheet then we can go back to craigslist
and start grabbing our information
so when you have selector gadget
installed you should see it at the top
right of your screen up in chrome
you can click on it once and now as you
move your mouse over your browser you'll
see different elements on the page being
highlighted
essentially if you start clicking on
data selector gadget will try to
interpret what you're trying to select
and then generate a tag associated with
all of that information
so for this example we want to grab the
listing name
the price the date and the location in
parentheses
and the quickest way to do this instead
of breaking that up into those four
different categories
we actually want to click on whatever
parent node that contains
that information so in this case instead
of clicking on
just the text here that would only get
us the names of the listings but it
wouldn't get us the other information
so i'll clear that selection and instead
try to click on the container that
contains all that information
which looks like it's down here so i'll
click on that once and you can see all
these yellow boxes populate and it
includes
the name of the listing the date the
price and the location so once we've got
our appropriate data selected we go down
to the bottom right where it says xpath
and then this box will pop up we'll copy
this information
hit ok and go back to our spreadsheet
and paste that in a cell
so now we can call the import xml
command pass in the url as our first
parameter and our xpath as a second
parameter
and we can see all the listings populate
in our spreadsheet we've got the date
the name of the listing and the price
but also the location in just one cell
now if i want to get the price
specifically as its own column i could
maybe do some regular expression but i'm
going to show you how we can just get
the price selected with selector gadget
first i'm going to format this column
just so it cuts off the text and i'll
add our prices in this new column over
here so back to our craigslist page
we'll go ahead and clear the selection
and now like i mentioned we just want to
grab this price so we click it once
but you see that the price is selected
two times for each listing now both
at the top here and down here in the
description so just to explain more
about how selector gadget works
anything that's yellow if you click on
it'll deselect and anything that's not
yellow
it'll try to select so we want just
these bottom
prices selected but not the top ones so
i'll click on this up here and you can
see it only keeps
our bottom prices selected so we'll go
back down to the xpath button
copy this and go to sheets we'll paste
this new xpath up here and essentially
write the same command as before
import xml with the url and then this
new xpath of just the prices
and now you can see we have all the data
we wanted from those listings
now theoretically you don't need to use
selector gadget to actually scrape this
information you could go into inspect
element
and grab the xpath manually so i'll just
show you what that looks like
so over here i'll right click hit
inspect
and you can see that there are these
four tags the span the time
the a tag and another span all within
this paragraph tag
so this is what i meant by selecting the
container and if we didn't have selector
gadget and wanted to replicate this
result we would just need to specify
that we want all the information within
this p
class result info so i'll go back to our
spreadsheet
i'll get rid of this for now and instead
i'll make this slash slash which
essentially
says that we're not going to be in the
root of our nodes this is going to bring
us down to
any node that'll fit this description
the p tag where
the class name is going to be result
dash
info and you can see that even though
these expats are different they do
give you the same result now one thing
you need to be wary of when you're
scraping websites is that the data that
you
scrape might not contain all printable
characters
and that's a little hard to see because
if they're not printable they won't show
up but essentially one thing you should
do
is wrap your import xml in this clean
command and then wrap that in the array
formula command which you can
use the command shift enter shortcut to
call and when you hit enter it should
give you the same output but now it's
removed all of those unprintable
characters so the next example is going
to be techcrunch and i just wanted to
solidify that idea of selecting the
container
so we want to grab all of these articles
with the headline
the date and author and the description
so i'll grab selector gadget again
and instead of just clicking on one of
these attributes i'm going to try to
find the container that has all of them
so that looks like it's up here and i'll
click once and for some reason it's only
selecting
our premium content articles so i'll
click on another one of these articles
that isn't selected
and now you'll see it's turned the other
articles all yellow so we'll come back
down to the bottom right where it says
xpath
copy this and then paste this in our
google sheet
we can write the same command as before
where we pass in the url
and the xpath and you can see that it
populates our spreadsheet with all the
articles from techcrunch
and then the last example we're going to
combine both the power of selector
gadget tool but also the power of
knowing xpath to web scrape this yelp
page
so just like before we can start by
opening up selector gadget tool
grabbing the big container that contains
all the information we want
clicking on it once but now everything
on the page gets selected
so we'll just click somewhere to
deselect and select your gadget's pretty
smart so it figures out we just want the
restaurant listings and we'll follow the
same processes before
grabbing the xpath copying it going to
our spreadsheet we also do need to grab
the url so let's copy and paste that and
we'll write import xml
the url and the xpath except now google
sheets has scraped all the information
of each of these restaurants
into one cell per listing and we could
do some text cleaning to separate out
these texts into multiple columns but
there's a better way to do it just here
so we'll clear our selection and we'll
start by just
selecting the restaurant names so let's
do that first we click on that it also
selected this more so i'll deselect
there
and now it's selected burgers so i'll
deselect that oh it got some pages at
the bottom so let's deselect those too
so now we'll grab this x path copy that
and paste that
here and these are going to be our
restaurant names here we go
and now let's grab the phone number and
address so we could split it up again by
doing the phone number separately from
the address
but it looks like they are all in one
attribute so let's try
selecting this div tag that seems to
contain all these nodes
grab the xpath copy it we'll make a
column just on the right
so just so this isn't confusing i'll cut
this off we're going to paste this new
xpath of the address
and phone number and we'll write our
import xml formula
right here great and then that seemed to
cooperate pretty well but
the last thing i want and this is where
xpath is going to come in
is the rating now if i were just to grab
this rating
and use the xpath and do the same
process as before
we'll go ahead and cut these off i'll
paste that here and write our import xml
command
we just get an empty cell we've written
the command but
nothing populates so let's go further
into the code and see what's going on
let's right click and hit inspect
element and it looks like
this is the div tag that we selected and
inside the div tag
there's the image of the stars but
there's actually no text or anything
that indicates what the star rating is
we do see though that there is this
attribute called rei dash label equals
4.5 star rating
and if we were to go down here inspect
we can see that it's now four star
rating so
the data is there we just need to figure
out how to get it well again this is
where knowing xpath helps
because we can go back to our code and
actually select the attribute
by adding a slash at the end and then an
and then
the name of the attribute we want to
grab the text for which is aria-label
and i'll hit enter it should rerun this
formula down here and we'll give it a
second to load
but there we go it gives us all the star
ratings and if we just want to extract
the actual numbers we'll run
our regex extract function and we can
pass in
slash d and possibly a decimal and then
possibly another number
and you can see we get our data so i
think selector gadget
and knowing xpath together can be really
useful
along with knowing this import xml
command in google sheets
i certainly won't say that this is
always the quickest solution but
it'll definitely be quicker than opening
python or r up in some situations
and you can do a lot of easy data
cleaning just from within google sheets
which is another huge pro
and if you're still curious about the
capabilities of web scraping either in
google sheets or even an
r i'd recommend checking out my other
videos right here and here but i just
want to thank you for watching
and i'll catch you in the next one